bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans savourgarde ce soir
un député qui s'apprête à mener une
bataille parlementaire cruciale dans
l'hémicycle bonsoir Florent bouer
bonsoir et merci d'être notre grand
témoin cette bataille c'est celle du
projet de loi sur l'immigration dont
vous êtes le rapporteur principal projet
de loi voté au Sénat cet après-midi dans
une version largement durcie alors
va-t-on vers un 493 y a-t-il une voix de
passage à l'Assemblée on va en parler
vous venez aussi de faire un rapport
dans le cadre d'une commission d'enquête
importante sur les groupuscules violents
après sainte Soline notamment on en dira
un mot également notre grand débat ce
soir Israël Hamas la guerre des images
depuis le 7 octobre c'est une première
dans l'histoire des guerres Israël
montre aux journalistes les vidéos du
massacre du ramas une projection a été
organisé ce soir à l'Assemblée pour les
députés bataille de communication où
chaque camp et bien essaie de prendre le
monde à témoin on en parle dans un
instant avec nos invités sur ce plateau
enfin noous affranchis ce soir
l'international avec Vincent ugu
l'économie Fanny guinochet et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée d'Elsa mondain Gava
voilà pour le menu on y va Florian
bouier ça vous regarde c'est tout de
[Musique]
suite regardez regardez ce qu'ils nous
ont fait c'est une guerre dans la guerre
la bataille des images entre Israël et
le Hamas dans un dispositif inédit
l'État hébreu a montré les vidéos du
massacre du 7 octobre à des journalistes
c'était hier et ce soir à leur demande
aux députés de l'Assemblée nationale
tandis que de leur côté les Palestiniens
diffusent les images des victimes des
civils et des bombardements israéliens
alors faut-il les montrer toutes ces
images et si oui comment nos émotions
nous empêchent-elles de penser le
conflit bonsir bonsoir François Cormier
bouigon bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes député renaissance du Cher membre
du groupe d'amitié France Israël vous
avez assisté à cette projection C y a
quelques quelques heures une heure à
peine ce film des massacres du 7 octobre
à l'Assemblée vous vous êtes également
rendu en Israël avec une délégation de
députés juste une semaine après le le 7
octobre vous aussi vous venez de le voir
ce film emmeric Caron bonsoir vous êtes
député apparenté enfin membre de la
France insoumise député du du parti rêve
et vous nous direz dans le cadre de ce
groupe d'amitié ce que vous vous avez
ressenti après après avoir vu ces images
bonsoir maris Burgot bonsoir très
heureuse de vous vous accueillir dans
cette émission vous êtes grand reporter
à France 2 reporter de guerre vous avez
l'habitude de des terrains de de conflit
et des et des images on a envie de
comprendre comment vous les choisissez
ces images qu'est-ce que vous décidez de
de montrer ou de ne pas montrer sur le
service public enfin bonsoir auir Lévis
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes spécialiste
des images de la Choa notamment des
archives de guerre maître de conférence
en études cinématographique à
l'Université Paris 8 Vincen Saint-Denis
votre dernierre ouvrage puissance
politique des images paru au PUF voilà
pour les présentations Florent Boudier
évidemment vous intervenez quand quand
vous le souhaitez avant de vous donner
la parole on va faire le point sur cette
guerre des des images qui se concentre
c'est l'actualité autour des hôpitaux de
Gaza avec mon camarade Stéphane
blakovski qui nous plante le décor tout
de suite on l'accueille bonsoir
Stéphane
bonsoir Miriam bonsoir à toutes et tous
alors il y a le film à l'Assemblée puis
il y a le terrain exactement ce soir à
l'Assemblée les députés qu'il souhaitait
ont donc pu voir ce film de trois gardur
qui a été réalisé par l'armée
israélienne à partir donc des images du
massacre du 7 octobre commis par les
terroristes du Hamas alors la première
projection de ce film pour faire un
petit historique a été lieu en Israël
c'estit le 23 octobre devant 200
journalistes ensuite le film a été
diffusé à l'ACN c'està-dire au parlement
israélien et puis euh vous voyez que
depuis Israël diffuse ce même film dans
une trentaine d'ambassades à travers le
monde afin que les images soient vues
par les journalistes euh du monde entier
alors il faut dire que depuis le début
de l'aréposte israélienne contre le
Hamas bien le nombre de victime civiles
à Gaza ne cessent d'augmenter donc
israël ne veut surtout pas qu'on oublie
que au début de ce conflit il y a les
atrocités commise par euh le Hamas et en
effet cette guerre elle a une
particularité un peu euh par par rapport
à d'autres conflit c'est que elle se
déroule sous les yeux de l'opinion
internationale qui s'y intéresse
énormément ce qui n'est pas le cas de
toutes les guerres je vous rappelle que
depuis le la fin avril il y a une guerre
au Soudan qui a fait donc plus de 7000
morts 5 millions de déplacés et on peut
pas dire que ça fasse la une du journal
télévisé tous les soirs tandis que euh à
Gaza bien Israël et le Hamas ce livre
donc a une guerre des images en plus de
la guerre avec des opérations militaires
on appelle ça la guerre euh de
l'information pour tenter donc de
rallier une partie de l'opinion
internationale chacun à sa cause donc
vous le disiez on peut voir un exemple
de cette guerre de l'information autour
de l'hôpital d'alchifa Gaza qui est le
le plus grand hôpital de Gaza où le
Hamas dénonce les opération militaire
d'Israël contre cet hôpital en parlant
de crime de guerre tandis que les
Israéliens disent oui mais en fait le
Hamas a utilise des boucliers humains et
sous ses hôpitaux il a creusé des
tunnels dans lequels il cache des armes
et et desqg d'ailleurs pour prouver sa
bonne foi donc Israël utilise les images
utilise la possibilité qu'elle a de
d'envoyer des équipes protégées par ces
soldats sur place et elle montre la
preuve de ces tunnel que ces tunnel
existe c'est un tunnel secret ça fait
partie du même étage et ça descend ici
c'est un tunnel secret personne ne peut
le
trouver là c'est l'hôpital
ranti et ici c'est l'endroit où j'ai
montré le tunnel
je veux que vous
voyez alors évidemment les médias qui
eux soutiennent la cause palestinienne
comme la Chelle aljzira ne présente pas
forcément la même version à leurs
téléspectateurs je vous montre des
articles publiés sur le site d'algesira
voyez qui disent que en fait ce que
Israël présente comme l'entrée d'un
tunnel serait plutôt un réservoir d'eau
et aljzira insiste beaucoup sur les
conséquences humanitaires des opérations
militaires notamment dans cet hôpital
alchifa il y avait des il y a toujours
des bébés prématurés on s'inquiète pour
leur vie puisque les ouveus qui servent
à les maintenir en vie ne peuvent plus
fonctionner faute d'électricité donc
finalement par rapport à l'attitude
internationale sur le conflit et bien on
voit que les pays occidentaux qui
soutenaient Israël depuis le début en
donnant le droit de se défendre sont
aujourd'hui aussi attentif au fait que
sur le plan humanitaire ça devient
dramatique à Gaza donc on a des une
situation où Biden aujourd'hui a dit il
faudrait quand même protéger les
hôpitaux en s'adressant aux Israéliens
une position d'ailleurs partagée par
l'Europe où on dit oui oui on sait que
le gamin pardon le Hamas utilise des
boucliers humains mais cependant on
demande à Israël de faire preuve de
retenu donc voilà malgré sa supériorité
militaire évidente sur le terrain est-ce
qu'il y a un risque pour Israël de
perdre la guerre des images la guerre
des informations j'imagine que ça sera
une des questions du débat ce soir
absolument merci Stéphane je vais
commencer avec vous maris Burgo vous
revenez
d'Israël la communication c'est toujours
centrale dans tous les conflits mais
dans celui-là particulièrement au tout
début après le 7 octobre il y a eu un
déferlement d'images absolument atroces
sur les réseaux sociaux par le Hamas par
des civils israéliens comment vous vous
avez fait sachant que vous avez tout vu
notamment sur cette chaîne Instagram du
Hamas pour faire le tri dans tout ça
alors moi je travaille pour le journal
télévisé de 20h donc on fait très
attention nous à ce à ce qu'on diffuse
il est pas question de montrer tout ce
que nous avons vu euh
donc on les
regarde j'ai moi j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps sur la chaîne télgram du Hamas par
exemple qui avait déjà diffuser la
plupart de ce qu'on voit dans dans le
film que qui par exemple a été diffusé
aujourd'hui nous on choisi de montrer ce
qui nous paraît le plus pertinent ce qui
nous paraît le de ce qui nous semble le
plus important pour notre public pour
qu'il comprenne la violence de ce qui
s'est passé tout en ne montrant pas
totalement par parce qu'à cette heure-là
il y a des enfants devant la télévision
donc c'est notre devoir de ne pas tout
montrer hier vous avez montré par
exemple parce qu'on voit bien que la
guerre se concentre aujourd'hui sur la
question cruciale des hôpitaux on sait
ce qui s'est passé déjà avec les les les
erreurs autour de alali et et et ces
erreurs de journalistes qui ont pu
d'ailleurs faire leur met à coule pas
sur l'origine de la frappe ce qui se
passe à alchifa comment ça se passe il a
vous avez montré les bébés qui sont en
en en danger de mort les bébés
prématurés au 20H comment vous parviens
de cette image par exemple est-ce que
c'est c'est un c'est à l'intérieur de
l'hôpital ce sont les médecins ça passe
par le ministère de la Santé du Hamas
comment ça se passe ça passe par le
ministère du du de la santé du Hamas ces
imagesl et nous on les recoupe
énormément c'est-à-dire que nous avons
un réseau de de de de contact à Gaza
depuis de longues années nous avons un
bureau permanent à Jérusalem et des gens
qui sont en contact permanent avec des
personnes à Gaza donc on a plusieurs
sources pour vérifier ce que l'on
diffuse mais par exemple sur l'histoire
d'alchifal C cet immense hôpital dont
vous parlez personne n'a jamais pu
vérifier de manière indépendante qu'il y
a bel et bien le un énorme QG du Hamas
dans dans les sous-sols de de cet
hôpital personne n'a jamais pu le
prouver de façon indépendante alors
Israël diffuse cette fameuse image très
très léchée d'une de de de d'une
infographie où il en 3D en 3D mais enfin
ça pour l'instant ça ne prouve rien
alors il faut expliquer à ceux qui nous
regardent qui n'auraient pas vu ces ces
images c'est une reconstitution en 3D
faite par tsal pour les journalistes
pour démontrer que en dessous dans les
tunnels se situent les sièges
stratégiques du Hamas oui et comme
Israël est en train d'une certaine
manière de perdre la bataille de
l'opinion mondiale il lui faut montrer
encore plus d'images nous prouver et
nous prouver à nous journalistes que oui
il y a bel et bien sous l'hôpital
alchifa un un QG du Hamas et des
armements et cetera et cette opération
elle elle elle a continué aujourd'hui
l'hôpital ranti don dont vous
parliez l'hôpital pour enfants c'était
c'est pas un journaliste d'ailleurs le
la personne qui parlait c'est un un
représentant de de tou bien s soit bien
clair et donc lui il il nous
vend son histoire qui est à l'hôpital
aussi il y a un tunnel et ce que vous
voyez là c'est un tunnel et il ils ont
emmené des journalistes il y avait
plusieurs journalistes embédid dans ce
voyage là et on est on on prend tout
cela avec on le regarde on essaie de le
prendre avec des pincettes mais pour
l'instant on ne sait pas si c'est
vraiment réel voyez alors justement
c'est c'est la c'est la question comment
comment vous faites par exemple quand
l'armée vous propose d'entrer à Gaza CNN
est rentré avec l'armée dans cet hôpital
ce soir Agnès varamian votre consur de
de France 2 est rentré avec
l'armée forcément on y va c'est une
chance pour un journaliste de déjà
pouvoir témoigner et ouvrir les yeux il
y a pas de d'Ét dames làdessus non il
n'y a pas d'état d'â en Ukraine aussi on
est souvent entre guillemets avec
l'armée pour aller sur les zones les
plus dangereuses donc ce il n'y a pas
d'état d'âme à aller avec l'armée
israélienne l'essentiel c'est de de
prendre du REC
avec ce qu'on accepte de nous montrer de
tout décoder et de et de et de croiser
nos sources de voir si ce qu'on nous dit
est vraiment vrai agès baramian qui est
rentré donc une des premières à rentrer
dans Gaza nous a montré combien c'était
détruit par exemple bon mais c'est bien
que nous puissions le voir nous-même on
en est presque convaincu maintenant
parce qu'on voit les images mais nous
pouvons le dire nous y étions c'est
c'est toute c'est toute la valeur du
reportage même si c'est un reportage
avec
accompagné d'une certaine manière et
comment vous regardez les télévisions
dans les deux camps que montre Israël
les chaînes israéliennes et après je
fais circuler la parole et que montre je
pense à algzira les chaînes en continu
les chaînes arabes mais les les
Israéliens sur cette histoire là ont
montré beaucoup de choses finalement
même chez eux et à leur propre public
même si c'est difficile à voir parce que
parce que dès le début ils ont été dans
la sidération et dans et dans le début
il a fallu justifier quand même ce qui
allait arriver donc je je je je ne
trouve pas qu'Israël é é était tellement
dans la retenue sur ces images là au
contraire vous-même vous avez fait
beaucoup de terrain de guerre est-ce que
vous êtes poursuivi par C certaines
images alors oui euh mais je vous allez
en parler très bien moi je suis passée
d'une première sidération quand j'ai vu
ces images au lendemain du 7 et
rencontrer les les familles qui ont vu
ou qui ont ou qui étaient là
et c'est d'une violence et d'une
barbarie inouie notamment le le le la la
capacité qu'on qu'on eu certains de ces
terroristes du Hamas à à à piétiner les
morts comme s'il fallait faire encore
plus au-delà de la mort aller au-delà de
la mort c'est quelque chose que je qui
m'a beaucoup choqué ce qui me m'a m'a
sidéré aussi après quelques semaines
après et encore aujourd'hui ce sont les
nombreuses images d'enfants de Gaza
blessés trembl blanc de peur
d'effroid moi j'ai le même j'ai le même
sentiment de de de de
d'effroid dans les deux cas pour moi ce
sont des des civils dans les deux cas
des êtres humains le même sang donc
c'est alors je voudrais qu'on parle à
présent de ce film alors il se trouve
que voilà je l'ai vu la Chaîne
parlementaire a décidé de le voir avec
avec plusieurs de mes confrères je vais
vous je vais vous demander mais
j'aimerais bien avant qu'on voit la
réaction des députés va pas montrer
extrait évidemment de de ce film on a
pas la possibilité auir lesvie que vous
nous décriviez le
dispositif de de ces de ces vidéo monté
bout à bout euh expliquez-nous ce que
vous avez vu hier quel était le
dispositif oui alors il s'agit déjà d'un
montage en effet il s'agit pas d'une
suite arbitraire ou aléatoire d'extraits
qu'on aurait mis comme ça bout à bout
donc comme c'est un montage il est
articulé il est pensé il est légendé
c'est très important c'est-à-dire que
chaque image est donnée avec sa source
et les sources des images sont
différentes parmi les images il y a des
images tournées par les terroristes
eux-mêmes au moment où ils commettent
les massacres des images tourner le plus
souvent avec soit avec un téléphone
portable soit avec une petite caméra
GoPro et c'est important de le noter
alors je garde ça peut-être pour non
mais expliquer les GoPro des mini
caméras sur voà des petites caméras
qu'on peut harnacher au corps qu'on peut
porter par exemple sur le sur le front
ce qui permet à la caméra de suivre le
le mouvement du regard et c'est des
caméras donc qui libèrent à la fois les
mains puisque vous n'avez plus à tenir
l'objet qui libère le regard puisque
vous n'avez pas à cadrer et qui
finalement sont dans une espèce de prise
tout à fait permanente de de l'acte et
il ne s'agit plus de filmer c'est pas je
filme c'est ça filme ça filme et ça
filme pendant que je je je m'adonne à
une une sorte de de performance les
caméras qui sont très utilisé notamment
pour des performances sportif donc ça ça
ça montre qu'on est ici dans quelque
chose qui a à voir avec avec une sorte
d'exploit c'est c'est pour essayer de
rentrer dans la dans la dans la mise en
scène d'autres types d'images sont
celles des caméras de surveillance donc
des caméras de surveillance soit public
àderot par exemple soit privé dans le
kibbut de BR donc les caméras des
familles elles-mêmes qui s'articulent à
des images qui sont celles prises par
les théories c'est très important qu'il
y ait différentes sources d'imag puisque
ça permet au spectateurs d'être arraché
ou en tout cas d'être retiré d'une forme
de tête à-tête de collocque insouten
avec le point de vue unique qui serait
celui des des des terroristes et avec
des images dans lesquelles cette il y a
pas d'autres mots cette jouissance de de
la terreur qu'on inflige nous serait
partagé dans laquelle on serait comme
comme livré donc c'est important et le
troisème type d'images sont des images
prises par les victimes elles-mêmes très
souvent au téléphone portable dans les
lieux où elles se cache et où on voit
qu'elles attendent avec angoisse
l'arrivée des des terroristes Emeric
Caron c'est vrai que ce qui ce qui
frappe c'est la jouissance
l'euphorie des des terroristes qui
parfois appellent leur famille j'ai tué
des Juifs de mes propres mains pourquoi
vous avez voulu voir ce film et
qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti
qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus
marqué d'abord si je vou voir ce film
c'est parce que je suis un ancien
collègue de Marise Burgo qu'on était sur
le terrain ensemble à une époque et que
donc dans dans ma manière de de de de
d'appréhender les choses de la vie et
aussi maintenant que je suis je suis
député ça a pas changé toujours envie de
d'être informé de savoir de donc si on a
des images à disposition pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas aller aller les voir vous
demandez une réaction c'est je pense que
la même réaction que que toute personne
humainement normalement constitué qui a
vu ces images c'estàdire le dégoût
l'effroid
laassidération voilà donc c'est la
barbarie c'est la barbarie qui
s'enchaîne sur 45 minutes avec un côté
euh dramatiquement
redondant avec un écœurement hein très
vite puisque c'est toujours le même
genre de massacre bon et et les nuances
à nous intéressent plus c'est bon euh
après la question qui se pose c'est euh
effectivement pourquoi avons-nous vu ces
images nous parlementaires et est-ce
qu'on devait les voir est-ce qu'on VO je
précise que cé à la demande hein de
Matthieu Le Fèvre le président du groupe
d'amitié France Israël voilà donc à la
demande d'un groupe précis tout vous dit
les députés c'est pas tous les députés
dans leur ensemble donc il faut quand
même aussi avoir conscience que c'est un
film qui est réalisé par l'armée
israélienne qui est montée par l'armée
israélienne et que donc bien évidemment
il y a un but derrière la projection de
ces images et moi je fais partie de de
ceux qui disent très bien nous les avons
vu il faudrait que nous puissions voir
également maintenant un film qui nous
montre ce qui se passe à Gaza en ce
moment maris en
parlait Mar moi je trouve que tout ce
qu' a dit Mar était parfaitement juste
au auprès je suis comme maris Burgot je
suis euh euh dégoûté ce que je viens de
voir et mais je suis aussi complètement
bouleversé par les images de ces enfants
eu qui sont tués qui sont déchiquetés
qui sont rendus orphelin euh et par
centaines et par milliers et dont je
suis désolé de le dire on ne parle pas
assez et nous en tant que parlementaire
si on nous dit il faut que vous voyez
ces images pour être informé je dis
d'acord est-ce que vous renvoyez dos à
dos les deux choses juste pour
comprendre est-ce que pour vous le
massacre du 7 octobre vous venez de voir
les
images et et la repost sont équivalentes
je pose la question mais je comprends
pas votre question en réalité vous
entendez quoi par si non non non parce
qu'il y a des sous-entendus dans votre
question qu'est-ce que vous entendez par
équivalence pour il y a une intention de
de tuer enfant un enfant un enfant qui
est tué un enfant innocent qui est tué
c'est un drame surtout quand cet enfant
n'aurait pas dû mourir quand il a été
tué par l'injustice ou par ou voilà
alors vous allez me dire si c'est une
bombe en repost a c'est moins grave que
non ça c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
pas entendre surtout quand que je je dis
je vous pose la question l'intention de
donner la mort qu'on a qu'on a pu voir
dans ce film et les les bombardements
pour vous sont équivalents je vous POS
la question ce qui est équivalent ce qui
est équivalent mais manière très rapide
c'est d'un côté comme de l'autre ce sont
des crimes de guerre mais pardon mais
alors comme vous m'ave dit je pense
comme maris Burgot je ne pense pas tout
à fait ça je je ne mets pas sur le même
niveau ces deux chosesl moi il y a tout
à fait c'est tout à fait vrai une
intention de tuer dans un che chez mais
je parlais dans l'émotion que vous aviez
ressenti là-dessus làdus vous rejonez
François Cormier boligou ce que vous
venez de voir déjà vous vous vous
n'aviez
absolument pas voulu vous épargner quoi
que ce soit puisque vous étiez déjà sur
place vous avez visité la morgue au sud
de té Aviv vous avez rencontré déjà des
soldats des victimes pourquoi vous y
êtes allé et qu'est-ce qui vous a marqué
mais nous sommes des députés nous avons
à prendre des décisions je suis membre
de la commission de la Défense nationale
nous avons à prendre des décisions pour
mener la guerre ici et là pour envoyer
nos hommes ici et là et notre rôle de
député c'est de voir la vérité en face
de voir la réalité en face la réalité
crue la réalité barbare et je suis allé
en Israël non seulement pour apporter le
témoignage de la solidarité de la France
à l'État d'Israël seule démocratie du
Proche Orient également pour être au
côté des victimes des FA is des otages
franco-israéliens et des familles des
des otages de façon générale mais
également pour voir sur le terrain et
pour pouvoir revenir témoigner de ce qui
s'est passé parce que moi je suis un
adversaire résolu du
relativisme israël est une démocratie
elle utilise les armes pour protéger ses
civils elle utilise les armes pour
protéger l'existance même de l'État
d'Israël parce que l'État d'Israël a été
créé après la guerre pour servir de
refuge à un peuple qu'on a voulu
exterminer 6 millions d'êtres humains
Juifs exterminés par les nazis est-ce
que nous avons vu j'entends que la
politique est importante et que vous
vouliez rappeler les l'histoire mais je
voudrais savoir vous êtes aussi un homme
qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti
peut-être qu'il y a une scène en
particulier qui vous a marqué dans ce
film est-ce que est-ce que vous voulez
nous en parler ce que nous avons vu
Myriam Ankawa c'est dans la réalité ce
que nous avons pu dire dans des récits
pour ceux qui s'intéressent à l'histoire
pour ceux qui s'intéressent à l'humanité
des récits de pogrome des récits de la
Choa ce que nous avons vu c'est ça
poursuivre des êtres humains parce
qu'ils sont juifs les tuer parce qu'ils
sont juifs le mot d'israen n'est pas
prononcé he pr pronce et pas le mot
israélien les exterminer parce qu'ils
sont juifs mettre le feu au
cadavre comme ça s'est passé pendant la
Seconde Guerre mondiale ce sont des
images de porome ce que ce que nous
avons vu et une vie vaut une vie oui
c'est vrai et moi mon cœur est déchiré
autant par les victimes israéliennes que
par les victimes de palestiniennes mais
ce qu'il faut rappeler c'est que le
Hamas ne protège pas sa population
jamais il s'en sert euh comme un outil
de guerre qu'il mène contre Israël pour
l' pour euh exterminer Israël pour
détruire Israël aucun civil palestinien
n'est protégé euh dans les 500 km
sou-terrain que
euh le le Hamas a fait construire avec
les financements que qui leur sont donné
on voit évidemment j'ai le CP fendu
quand je vois les hôpitaux d'enfants où
c'est les les bébés
prématuré meurt faute de de pouvoir être
déplacé et d'avoir des soin mais que
fait le Hamas de l'énergie dont il
dispose est-ce que c'est pour les
hôpitaux ou est-ce que c'est pour ses
actions de terrorisme c'est pour ces
actions de terrorisme et donc il y a une
grande différence à faire à ce niveau-là
alors je voudrais qu'on revienne aux
images on est allé voir à la sortie la
réaction des députés puis ensuite au f
lesville vous nous direz ce qu'on y voit
parce que il faut les décrire regardez
c'est un sujet de Marion
Lefèvre à peine sortie de la salle de
projection l'émotion est palpable c'est
une atteinte à l'humanité tout entier
qui est la nôtre qu'on a vu dans cette
dans cette salle de projection je pense
que c'était un moment très difficile
mais très nécessaire face à tous les
relativismes et face à tous les risques
d'oubli il y a des gens qui sont train
qui rentrent dans le négationnisme il y
a des députés français aujourd'hui qui
disent que que ça n'a pas existé mais
pas 10 ans après un mois après les corps
calcinés que vous voyez de jeunes filles
de de femmes âgées de ces corps c'est
c'est des images de de de de la Cho avec
les images du mal absolu de la
sauvagerie de la barbarie la plus la
plus grave et de de voir ces images de
voir de quoi l'humanité est capable une
réaction était particulièrement attendue
celle de David guireot le député de la
France insoumise après ses propos
relativisant les actes du Hamas il y a
quelques
les boucliers humains c'est Israël qui a
utilisé on sait ça c'est prouvé le bébé
dans le four ça a été fait en effet par
Israël depuis il a reconnu sur le réseau
social x s'être trompé et nié toute
minimisation de l'attaque après la
projection il a à nouveau reconnu son
erreur dans une conférence
récente j'ai donné l'impression de
traiter tout cela avec
légèreté donc je me suis venu
m'assurer que je ne referai pas cette
erreur je suis vous le savez dans cette
assemblée l'un des plus féroces critique
de l'État
israélien l'un des plus farouches
défenseurs du droit des Palestiniens à
vivre libre et
digne dans ce combat là ça fait
plusieurs semaines que je vois des
images très difficiles du nettoyage
ethnique à Gaza mais malgré la peine la
douleur qui me secoue tous les jours je
crois que j'oublierai jamais de
respecter tous les morts voilà le
respect des des morts au f lev je
voudrais que vous reveniez sur le
dispositif la lumière est allumée ça les
les représentants de l'ambassade il
tiennent pendant la projection oui alors
la projection à laquelle j'ai assité
mais je crois que c'était la même chose
aujourd'hui la lumière éta allumée ce
qui a pour effet de de réduire toute
possibilité de spectacularisation
c'estàdire on n'est pas en train de voir
un film dans lequel on s'installe et où
on serait dans une espèce comme ça de de
de de rapport au spectacle on est dans
une activité euh où on prend des notes
où on lit des traductions puisque il y a
il y a plusieurs langues dans la dans le
dans le film et donc on est on est dans
une attitude active vis-à-vis des images
et on n'est pas livré à ces images comme
comme dans une espèce de spectacle de de
cération pure frpp mis à part C
évidemment effroyable et et très
éprouvant à regarder mais ce qui frappe
c'est que il n'y a pas tant de scènes
montrant les exactions en train d'être
commises il y a cette scène qui
peut-être vous a marqué comme elle elle
nous a marqué ici à LCP ce sont c'est
cette famille ce père et c'estes et ses
deux fils et là on est dans l'horreur en
acte alors en effet par rapport au les
les images ou les atteintes au corps
sont les plus dures sont souvent des
images fixes donc des photographies ou
des images où les corps sont déjà enfin
les personnes sont déjà mortes ce qui
veut dire que ce qui n'est pas montré
dans le film alors je ne sais pas s'il
dispose de ces images ou pas mais on
peut imaginer que il doivent avoir en
réserve c'est le moment de
l'effectuation de ces crimes sur des
personnes vivantes et souffrantes
c'est-à-dire que ça ça n'est pas montré
euh on voit il y a certaines images où
il y a des fusillades mais je veux dire
quand on voit les les les corps calcinés
il y a très peu d'images où on voit les
il y a une image de de tentative de de
décapitation avec on voit une personne
on voit une personne blessée en train de
de de succomber et des personnes avec
une pioche essayer de séparer la sa tête
du reste de son encore et donc de
l'achever on voit ces chosesl on voit
des gens cachés sous les tables dans les
kibuts dans leur maison dans les kibuts
et les les les terroristes être là bien
les regarder bien regarder où ils sont
il y en a un là il y en a un là et après
les tuer les achever la scène des deux
des deux petits garçons et de le et de
leur père qui va se jeter sur la grenade
pour oui alors il y a une on pour éviter
leur mort avec cette espèce de
tranquillité aussi de du terroriste filé
essentiellement avec les caméras de
surveillance donc avec cette espèce de
point de vue sur plomban euh où le père
est tué donc devant le devant ses ses
deux enfants et les deux enfants se se
réfugient et eux même sont blessés se
réfugient donc dans chez eux et il y a
un moment assez sidérant où les deux
enfants bon essayent de échang se
demandent comment ils vont et le un des
terroristes entre et avec une
tranquillité absolument inouï se sert
dans le frigo et
boitorger du coca ca dans une espèce
comme ça de de quotidieneté d'un d'un
d'un acte comme si faisit ça tous les
jours parce qu'à priori c'est pas c'est
pas non plus son son activité
quotidienne mais le détachement et donc
l'absence absolue d'empathie avec
laquelle il boit son sa bouteille de
Coca-Cola nous dit quelque chose en
effet de ce rapport à l'autre homme qui
n'est plus perçu comme un autre h HM
Emeric Caron faut-il les les montrer
plus largement à ceux qui le souhaitent
ces imagesl après avoir vu ce film
qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez d'abord il y a il y a dans dans
le pays du du négationnisme du
relativisme est-ce que en montrant ces
images aux journalistes il les condamne
à des personnes qui sont qu'il y a
encore des gens dans ce pays qui
imaginent qu'il n'y a pas eu des actes
terroristes qui ont été perpétrés par le
Hamas le 7 octobre je crois que tout ça
étit quand même très largement documenté
ce film a d'ailleurs été montré à vos
collègues journalistes déjà depuis
plusieurs semaines et donc on en a lu
les uns et les autres on avait déjà eu
un contte-rendu finalement très très
précis de ce qu'on a de ce qu'on a
regardé aujourd'hui donc j'ai quand même
du mal à croire qu'il y aurait peut-être
une vocation éducative non non pas pas
forcément éductiveative informative je
crois ça c'est la première chose
deuxième chose tout le monde ne peut pas
les voir ces images qui les voit d'abord
faudrait que ce soit des gens qui qui a
envie en étant prévenu quand même
vraiment de l'effet à long terme que ça
peut avoir sur ces personnes donc moi je
suis j'ai toujours je je quand j'étais
reporter jeouvrais des conflits je
pensais qu'en effet nous devions montrer
les les les les cadavres et les horreurs
de la guerre qu'on devait pas montrer
une vision etdulcoré parce que la guerre
c'est atroce et que donc il ne faut pas
que les gens qui regardent le JIT chez
eux en mangeant le soir regarde ça comm
une espèce de légèreté donc je je suis
pour qu'on montre moi c'est pour ça que
j'y suis allé aussi je suis pour qu'on
voit que les gens VO la réalité de de la
barbarie mais avec énormément de de
précautions AR Burgo non mais c'est vrai
il ne faut pas trop édulcorer c'est
évident à trop édulcoré les gens ne sont
pas informés
c'est il y a une réalité euh qu'il faut
quand même montrer avec en respectant
les n nos les gens les téléspectateurs
leurs émotions leurs enfants qui sont
peut-être devant les encrants et cetera
mais d'ailleurs je précise que quand on
a montré aux journalistes ce film les
porte-paroles de l'ambassade ont dit
qu'il y a beaucoup d'images qui n'ont à
à dessin qui ne sont pas présentes les
viols les femmes beaucoup d'enfants
d'ailleurs la plupart ont le visage
flouté dans le film et nous nous nous
floutons systématiquement tout les
images des enfants évidemment c'est
parfaitement normal François corn béjon
je je crois qu'il est important de de
montrer ces images pourquoi d'abord
parce que les derniers témoins de la
Choa sont en train de disparaître et
nous devons montrer ce qu'est la haine
antisémite j'étais au Mémorial de la
chois la semaine dernière avec Herbert
Traube 98 ans un des derniers escapés
des pogromes de Vienne il faut
absolument qu'on ait conscience de ce Ce
à quoi conduit la haine antisémite
première chose la deuxième chose il faut
que nos concityens et conscience de ce à
quoi aboutit le fondamentalisme
religieux ces terroristes du Hamas que
l'on a vu tuer froidement les gens et
même s'en réjouir et même revendiquer
ces crimes sont des gens qui ont été
décivilisés par le fondamentalisme
religieux islamiste qui est un danger
partout sur la planète et donc nous
devons le savoir nous devons regarder la
vérité crue en face et nous en protéger
auir LVI puis je vous donne la parole em
Caron offir LVI vous êtes un spécialiste
de l'image vous êtes aussi historien
est-ce qu'il y a un parallèle à faire
déjà à partir de ce film avec d'autres
crimes dans l'histoire on entendait le
député Cormier boligon parler de la Choa
on peut penser au ensas grpen aussi
est-ce que vous vous vous voyez des
correspondan alors sur la nature des
crimes on pourrait en effet trouver des
des parallèles dans dans la violence et
dans l'extrémité de la violence en
revanche il y a une différence qui est
fondamentale c'est que le crime nazi
trouve son accomplissement dans sa
propre disparition c'estàdire on fait
disparaître toutes les traces faut pas
qu'il y ait d'image on fait disparaître
les centres de mise à mort il ne reste
rien d'ailleurs lanzman fait tout un
film dans lequel on ne voit que des
lieux vides là le crime du Hamas trouve
son accomplissement dans sa monstration
c'est pour ça que j'insistais sur le
fait qu'on ne filme pas en cadrant
puisque d'ordinaire il y a un témoin qui
filme quelqu'un qui commet un acte mais
là l'acte est absolument consubstantiel
du fait de le filmer puisquen réalité
montrer et tué c'est un seul et même
acte h oui le terrorisme quasiment en en
direct em Caron il y a il y a des otages
euh on a parlé de de de ce de cette
guerre en direct sur les réseaux sociaux
il est il est possible que il y ait il y
ait d'autres atrocités vous pensez sur
avec le monde à témoins sur sur les
réseaux c'est c'est ce n'est pas exclu
sur les otages si s'il y a voilà des
difficultés avec les les négociations si
il y a une une forme
d'instrumentalisation desidment
évidemment et malheureusement évidemment
et et malheureusement oui euh
des exécutions pour le dire franchement
je pense à ça c'est on s'attend au pire
je n'en sais je n'en sais rien et on
prie tous pour et qu'évidemment ça
n'arrive pas euh quand même un point
encore sur la diffusion des images il y
a quand il y a quand même parce que vous
vous faisiez référence aux images de de
la Choa et ainsi de suite le fait
qu'elle soit diffusée ainsi à la
représentation nationale nous pose quand
même question
euh parce que des images d'abord on est
dans un conflit avec deux partis
avec deux partis et je le redis nous
devons avoir des images do pas exonérer
la responsabilité d'Israël dans la
manière dont
n'est pas une guerre entre deux états
emmeric Caron c'est une guerre entre un
État démocratique débat à son début
c'est je terminer mon propos se
revendiquer de la démocratie ne vous
autorise pas à vous affranchir des
règles du droit international ce moment
il a des crimes de guerre qui sont en ce
moment des crimes de guerre qui sont
commis par très bien donc vous dites ce
soirz je vais vous laisser débattre non
non c'est intéressant pour ceux quicout
vous dites ce soir que l'armée
israélienne neevient pas au droit
international qu'il ne commet pas de
crime de guerre le droit international
vous dit que lorsque
l'adversaire prend en bouclier des
civils vous pouvez pas le dro de tuer
les civils comme ça vous
Arous ici il s'agit d'exonérer pas
exonérer Isral de
la expt de l' par de G expert de l'ONU
non mais enf juste vent le mot de la
fin on essaie de réfléchir sur cette
guerre des images dans poliques nous
sommes des politiques et nous recevons
des images d'un côté du
conflit les images lorsqu'on veut
traiter un fait d'actualité déjàes sont
traité par des journalistes souvent Mar
le rappelé il y a un filtre il y a des
choix il y a des un contexte et aussi il
y a des historiens ensuite ce sont les
historiens qui vont vous parliez ça
c'est Stéphan blackovski qui raconéit
tout à l'heure l'histoire des tunnels le
grand flou non et vous aussi Marie
stiier on n pas pu documenter on na peut
pas prouver réellement qu'il y a
réellement des QG du Hamas sous les
hôpitaux on n pas on ne peut pas la
tester et voyez on est dans une guerre
de communication et ça je crois que il y
a donc quelque chose qui nous manque
aussi à nous aujourd'hui parlementaire
s'appelle le recul merci on s'arrête là
on s'arrête là je pense que on peut se
mettre d'accord sur la question du recul
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
débattre sur LCP vous restez avec moi
Florent BOURD pardon j'aurais pu vous
donner la la parole mais voilà il y
avait vraiment beaucoup à dire avec nos
intervenants dans une dizaine de minutes
les parties pris de nos AF franchi ce
soir le regard de Vincent e jeu sur le
revirement du président sur le conflit
au Proche Orient Fanny guinochet va nous
parler d'une volteface du gouvernement
qui finalement renonce à supprimer les
tickets resto comme mode de paiement de
ses courses au supermarché et puis de
quoi nous parlerz-vous ce soir dans
Bourbon Express Elsa et bien ça change à
l'Assemblée la question la séance de
question au gouvernement mais aussi les
semaines de l'Assemblée je vous en parle
dans quelques instants à tout de suite
Elsa mondingava à tout de suite les amis
mais d'abord on va parler de votre
actualité Florent bouier c'est une
bataille politique cruciale qui vous a
attend dans l'hémicycle vous êtes le
rapporteur principal du projet de loi
sur l'immigration qui arrive le 11
décembre à l'Assemblée nationale vous
êtes aussi l'auteur d'un rapport dans le
casadre d'une commission d'enquête sur
les grouuscules violents regardez c'est
dans l'invitation d'élène banduel et on
en parle juste
après si on vous invite Florent bouer
c'est parce que vous avez une double
actualité vous rendez aujourd'hui les
conclusions de la commission d'enquête
sur les groupuscules violents lors de
manifestations
député de Gironde depuis 2012 vous êtes
le rapporteur de cette commission qui
constate après 6 mois de travaux une
montée inextricable de la violence lors
des manifestations elle est de plus en
plus légitimée y compris dans les dans
les discours politiques et le fait par
exemple de ne pas dénoncer cette cette
violence est en soit déjà déjà un
problème ultra gauche ultra gilet jaune
activiste écolo vousz notamment étudier
l'organisation de ces groupuscules lors
des violents affrontements pendant les
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites et contre les mégabacines de
sainte Soline dans les Deux Sèvres votre
commission s'est d'ailleurs rendu sur
place début septembrevez sur les tables
derrière vous des objets qui sont
piquants coupants tranchants qui peuvent
constituer des projectiles des des armes
de jet et vous allez également trouver
des des des armes par destination nous
avons saisi notamment un un certain
nombre de boules de pétante qui sont
utilisés fréquemment par des activistes
comme projectiles et dont la létalité
est bien réelle en cas de jet puissant
je crois que c'est assez éloquent he
dans la ligne de mire de votre
commission le mouvement des soulèvements
de la terre dont la dissolution a
finalement été annulée par le Conseil
d'État ce ne sont pas simplement des
personnes qui ont pris la cause
environnementale à bras le corps mais
c'est aussi une structure qui accueille
en sonen en son sein des théoriciens de
la stratégie de confrontation violente
dans un mois c'est sur un autre terrain
que vous allez ferrailler dans
l'hémicycle celui de
l'immigration nommé rapporteur général
du texte vous serez en première ligne
sur le projet de loi du gouvernement un
texte adopté cet après-midi au Sénat et
extrêmement durci par la droite
suppression de laame et surtout fin de
l'article 3 qui prévoyait une
régularisation des S papiers dans les
métiers en tension c'est une belle
victoire l'article 3 c'était une machine
non seulement à régulariser mais c'est
une machine à fruder alors entre la
droite qui fait monter les enchères à
l'Assemblée et l'aile gauche de la
majorité qui compte bien réécrire le
texte n'avez-vous pas l'impression
Florent bouer de vous lancer dans un
combat perdu d'avance voilà elle vous a
adressé réponse furbon non pas du tout
moi je il y a un texte qui a été adopté
par le Sénat et je note à l'instant que
rotaillot revendique une victoire dans
cette victoire aux yeux de rotaillot de
Bruno rotillot pardon euh il y a par
exemple la validation on parle Sénat
d'une procédure de régularisation h on
va y venir voilà il a le SAL job dans
l'histoire c'est très ingrat très
difficile avec des chances de succès
faibles c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
l'un de vos collègues députés dans la
majorité souscouvert d'anonymat
franchement la mission elle est pas
facile ça vous le reconnaissez elle est
pas facile c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on
me la confie h parce que j'aime bien les
mission difficile je l'avais fait sur
d'autres Tex je pense à la lutte contre
le
séparatisme bon voilà moi j'aime bien
d'abord j'aime bien aller chercher les
points de vue
les confrontter quand c'est nécessaire
il faut trancher faut écouter là on est
dans la phase d'écoute parce que le
Sénat vient d'adopter le texte mais vous
croyez au vote
1493 p ar je crois non seulement à la
possibilité d'un vote et je souhaiterais
d'ailleurs qu'on puisse prolonger la
discussion au mois de janvier mais je
pense que sur ce sujet la majorité ne
sera pas divisée alors à quel prix
justement vous arriverez au vote est-ce
que c'est la droite qui fera la loi sur
ce texte très concrètement on va parler
du totem de cet article de cette loi
c'est l'article 3 la régularisation des
sans-papiers qui travaillent dans les
métiers en tenstion alors les sénateurs
ont largement durci cet article il ne
faudra plus 8 mais 12 mois de salaire
pour justifier une carte de séjour d'un
an mais surtout surtout ce titre sera
délivré au cas par cas à la discrétion
des préfets ça vous le gardez vous allez
réécrire pas sûr qu'on garde C non mais
je crois que vous savez que vous perdez
une large partie de votre propre camp si
on garde la discrétion des mais en
réalité nous nous sommes partis dans le
texte initial avec un droit opposable
automatique où personne au fond ne
pouvait dire grandchose c'était vous
répondez à tel critère vous aurez le
titre de séjour bon le Sénat dit c'est
le pouvoir discrétionnaire au contraire
général et absolu du préfet moi je pense
qu'on peut
avoir un dispositif j'en ai parlé ce
matin en r de groupe Renaissance où le
préfet pouir s'opposer mais sur des
motifs sur des motivations spéciales et
qui sont présenté dans la loi qui ne
sont
pas se mais j'en dirai pas plus parce
que les discussions sont pas terminées
mais je crois qu'on peut trouver c'est
pas une question d'entre deux moi ce qui
m'intéresse entre sachoulier président
de la commission des lois et vous il y a
quand même une sacrée une sacrée
différence allez nous sommes députés de
la même région la nouvelle Aquitaine
cette régularisation elle concerne les
sanspapiers qui sont aujourd'hui en
France ou ceux qui pourraient venir
demain ah très clairement elle ne
concerne que celles et ceux qui sont
déjà présents en France d'ailleurs le
système étant limité dans le temps avec
expérimentation qui s'arrêteraiit au 31
décembre 2026 personne parmi donc pas
d'appel d'air comme le crin parmi les
étrangers qui seraient en dehors du
territoire national aujourd'hui de
pourir bénéficier des régularisations
demain il faut quand même le redire où
sont les employeurs dans ce débat où est
le MDEF on l'entend pas il ne vous
soutient pas sur cette mesure là alors
nous avons auditionné tout à l'heure le
modè le le le M MF pardon
lapsus avec l'ensemble des rapporteurs
non ils soutiennent cette disposition il
considèent qu'elle a au contraire une
utilité réelle qu sont les secteurs
économiques au fond ce sont les secteurs
économiques qui font beaucoup appel à
l'intérim et donc on peut citer par
exemple mais je ne veux pas les montrer
du doigt en particulier c'est le BTP
notamment mais pas que le domaine aussi
de les services de logistique bon la
restauration l'hôtellerie aussi la
restauration l'hôellerie mais on voit
bien que on s'adresse à des personnes
qui sont présentes en France France sur
un dispositif qui serait temporaire
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2026 et je pense
contre le droit
automatique opposable et d'une certaine
façon non non négociable et un préfet
qui ferait d'une certaine façon ce qu'il
veut dans son département je pense que
pouront trouver des modalités qui sont à
la fois justes il y a des besoins
économiques il y a des nécessités
d'intégration par le travail je pense
qu'il n'y a rien de mieux que le travail
pour mieux intégrer et puis ensuite pour
des motifs pourront refuser parce que
par exemple il y a des menaces graves à
l'ordre publici parce que par exemple
oui on voit on voit à quoi vous vous
pensez quelques critères qui
conditionnent l'appréciation des préfets
mais mais pas de droit opposable total
on verra si ça fait une majorité ils
sont fiables et LR franchement vous vous
flicité du compromis durci au Sénat mais
les LR à l'Assemblée ils font preuve
quand même d'une certaine inconstance on
l'a vu sur les retraites regardez ce que
dit Aurélien Pradier dans la tribune
dimanche la position de fermeté et de
cohérence des républicains n'a pas été
suivie au Sénat
le texte qui en sort n'est pas celui des
républicains c'est celui des centristes
vous allez au devant d'un choint de
croix avec mais non mais les les LR ils
sont pas bien sur ce sujet ah oui en
réalité rappelez-vous au printemps
dernier il prés ils présente une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle une
autre ordinaire sur l'immigration et là
pendant une dizaine de jours on a ce
sentiment qu'enfin après les retraites
après la division ils sont capables de
se rassembler on a la fois Olivier
marlex on a Éric chotti on a Boillot
devant les Français devant les médias
bon 10 mois plus tard que reste-t-il il
reste d'abord des sénateurs er qui
valident un processus de régularisation
quelques jours après avoir dit il n'y
aura pas de texte sorti du Sénat et
régularisation zéro nous avons
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de députés
LR je pense que d'ailleurs ils ne sont
pas tous d'accord c'est normal ça
s'appelle la sensibilité de chacun qui
aujourd'hui considère que la position du
Sénat ne les arrange pas et d'ailleurs à
tel point que j'ai rarement vu un
président de groupe LR du Sénat devoir
écrit au députés au députés LR de
l'Assemblée nationale pour expliquer sa
position expliquer pourquoi il a accepté
lesrégularisation vous êtes confiant on
va plus vite parce que je voudrais qu'on
on laisse du temps pour nos affranchis
l'aide médicale d'État supprimé au Sénat
au profit d'une aide médicale d'urgence
lié aux maladies graves et aux douleurs
aigues bon courage pour définir ce ce
qui est aigu et ce qui ne l'est pas vous
êtes prêt à à réécrire le serment
d'Hippocrate ou pas non sur ce sujet
nous aurons un rapport rendu par Patrick
stéphanign et claudvin sans doute le 4
décembre d'ailleurs nous auditionneront
les courédacteurs dans la
foulée ils vont mettre au débat CBRE de
sujet moi je connais pas les conclusions
précises il y a eu des fuites dans la
presse je pense qu'il ne vont pas
proposer la suppression et puis dans ce
texte dans ce texte nous aurons pas à
traiter de la me en réalité et le
ministre de l'Intérieur l'a dit au Sénat
il n'y aura pas de dispositif de
suppression de la me dans le texte de
loi hmm oui il y a eu des revirements
hein le ministre de l'intérieur était
favorable à petite personnelle
maintenant il revient sur sa pas recadré
par la prère minist on passe sur les
quôass d'immigrés avec des plans fixés
chaque année au Parlement on verra
durcissement des conditions de
recroupement famili possible pour
l'asile est-ce qui n'est pas possible
pour le regroupement familial d'accord
bah c'est NON au moins c'est clair le
droit du sol largement remagé aussi non
et honnêtement c'est un éor automatique
à la National un énorme cavalier
législatif là aussi ça n'était pas dans
le et ben on verra je sais que vous
négociez depuis très longtemps que vous
voyez notamment ce petit groupe de
députés lot qui est centrale dans dans
cette affaire je voudrais qu'on dise
quelques mots sur votre rapport la
commission d'enquête sur les
groupuscules violents vous regrettez pas
la décision du Conseil d'État sur les
soulèvements de la terre qui a refusé de
dissoudre alors d'abord il est
indépendant c'est le juge suprême
administratif moi je respecte la
décision du Conseil d'État la très
grande difficulté c'est comment
démontrer que les soulèvements de la
terre qui sont un groupement
informel composé d'individus qui parfois
militent sincèrement et d'autres qui
sont véritablement dans une stratégie de
la confrontation violente voire dans
l'action violente concrète c'est de
démontrer le lien entre des individus
précis et le groupement en question et
le Conseil d'État a considéré qu'au
regard des actes qui étaient présentés
de leur degré de gravité la dissolution
ne s'imposait pas alors vous réclamez
une nouvelle stratégie du maintien de
l'ordre de travailler beaucoup en amont
avec les organisateurs des des
manifestations vous voulez aussi de
nouvelles armes mais alors vous voulez
des observateurs c'est pas le rôle des
journalistes dans ce genre de
manifestations qui peent dir violentes
ch ve deux choses un volet pénal plus
ferme notamment sur la question des
dissolutions il y a une série de
recommandations ou les interdictions de
manifester et puis ensuite j'aimerais
tellement que dans ce pays on abaisse le
degré de conflictualité sur c'est quoi
le maintien de l'ordre avec un débat qui
est absolument insupportable à front
renversé caricatural le dénis parfois
d'un certain nombre d'incidents de
l'autre au contraire la police tu bon et
je pense que pour ça il faut trois
éléments les journalistes et j'indique
dans le rapport qu'il faut clarifier
leur position notamment à l'occasion des
manifestations clarifier leur positions
ça n'est pas le cas ou par non parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des éléments dans
le schéma national du maintien de
l'ordre qui qui existent qui ont été
intégrés à la demande du Conseil d'État
il y a maintenant quelques années mais
l'application concrète parfois laisse à
désirer ce sont des
conféres observateur indépendant et
contrôle externe avec le Défenseur des
droits je pense que si on veut parler de
maintien de l'ordre en France ilut et
que on le fasse de de façon moins
caricaturale et excessive il faut qu'on
ait aussi des éléments qui objectivent
le débat et c'est ça qui m'intéresse à
travers ces propositions je renvoie aux
conclusions de de votre rapport dans un
très bon papier euh de de notre équipe
euh internet sur
LCP.fr merci beaucoup flurant bouier
vous restez avec moi c'est l'heure des
affranchis pour leur parti prix ils vont
vous faire réagir on les accueille tout
de suite bienvenue les afranchier pardon
pour le retard je sais que vous m'en
voulez mais on va y arriver Fanny
guinochet de franceino Vincent ugux pour
l'international on commence avec Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
c'est Elsa moningava qui nous la raconte
ce soir bonsoir Elsa bonsoir je vous
raconte l'histoire d'une assemblée qui
change un peu ses usages alors le plus
spectaculaire ce sera la semaine
prochaine avec la réforme des questions
gouvernement on en reparlera mais il y a
aussi des changements un peu moins
flagrants sur les semaines de
l'Assemblée c'est celle où les députés
défendent leur proposition de loi depuis
qu'elle est présidente à l'Assemblée
nationale il elbrun Pivet a encouragé
l'examen de texte transpartisan ça va
encore plus loin maintenant il y aura 40
% du temps réservé à telle initiative
transpartisan ça veut dire très
largement adopté au Sénat défendu par
beaucoup de députés de groupes
différents et nouveauté et bien voté par
la Conférence des Présidents ça avait
lieu ce matin alors on rappelle pour la
première fois la Conférence des
Présidents a voté quatre textes sont
inscrits à l'ordre du jour et oui ceux
qu'ont obtenu le plus de voix alors
roulement de tambourg on a un texte pour
interdire les cigarettes électroniques
jetables un autre sur les avoirs
criminels un sur les casinos un dernier
sur les cinémas on est allé demander à
siriel châelin présidente du groupe
écologiste et bien ce qu'elle pensait de
cette initiative laère nous on est
plutôt satisfait puisque le texte
présenté par Francesca paskini sur
l'interdiction des cigarettes
électroniques jetables obtenu une
unanimité ça sera le premier texte
présenté c'est votre proposition de loi
donc vous êtes satisfait mais le
vapotage les cinémas les casinos les
avoirs criminels c'est pas quand même
des choses révolutionnaires c'estàdire
que le consensus il se joue sur ces
choseslà alors non enfin là où je suis
d'accord avec vous c'est qu'en fait pour
le moment on est sur des textes certes
qui font du sens mais qui sont pas des
textes politiques et ça pour nous c'est
la prochaine étape c'est réussir à avoir
un vote en conférence du président une
inscription en semaine transpartisan de
textes qui font du sens politique alors
même son de cloche chez lot groupe
important ici à l'Assemblée pour
Bertrand pcher son président et bien il
faut juste de la bonne volonté de la
majorité vous considérez que certains
textes oui il faut consensus mais c'est
un peu un consensus mou vous aimeriez
qu'on aille quand même vers des textes
un petit qui change un peu plus la vie
des gens faut qu'on travaille sur des
textes plus politiques ça veut dire
qu'il faut que la majorité relative
demande pas en permanence le feu vert à
maquignon ou à l'Élysée c'est quand même
un petit peu comme ça que ça se passe
bon si on veut renforcer le Parlement
c'est à nous d'imposer nos textes donc
je pense qu'on est la croisée des
chemins il y a pas de majorité absolue
il faut qu'on construise ce nouveau
rapport de force moi je suis quand même
très content qu'on avance la semaine de
l'Assemblée c'est donc le 4 décembre un
premier pas vers plus d'initiativ
communes même si on le voit un le climat
à l'Assemblée en ce moment c'est pas
forcément la coconstruction oui mais
c'est bien quand ça voilà quand il y a
du consensus il faut pas se priver de le
dire merci beaucoup Elsa Vincent
qu'est-ce qui lui arrive à notre
président de la République sur le
conflit au Proche Orient est-ce qu'il a
changé d'avis est-ce que c'est un
revirement est-ce que ce sont des
nuances splendeur et misère du en même
temps 7e saison sur le fond Gazaoui
Emmanuel Macron c'est Chine à concilier
l'inconciliable maintenir le cap du
droit inalégable d'Israël de se défendre
tout en enjoignant à l'État hébreu de
respecter la norme humanitaire en clair
d'épargner les Palestiniens dans le seul
crime et d'avoir vu le jour au mauvais
moment au mauvais endroit pour autant
forcer de dcel une afflexion dans le
discours élyséen au fil des jours à
mesure que l'écrasante triposte de tsal
plongé la bande de Gaza dans une
détresse dentesque quit à saturé les
Mores à jeté sur des routes piégeuses
des hordes de nafr
qui donc a entamé le crédit
compassionnel que valet à Israël
l'abjecte barbarie du carnage du 7
octobre et bien Paris a durci le ton
alors quels sont pour vous les indices
de ce durcissement en voici deux le 3
novembre le chef de l'État àassine je le
cite que la lutte contre le terrorisme
ne justifie pas de sacrifier des civils
une semaine plus tard devant les caméras
de la BBC il s'insurge contre le sort
réservé citation là encore à ces bébés
ces femmes ces vieillards bombardés et
tués aucune justification aucune
légitimité pour Macron avant d'exhorter
Israël à mettre fin au matraquage lui
aura au moins eu le mérite de
s'affranchir des acropasies sémantiques
euh lui ne parle plus de pause ou de
trêve mais bellez bien de cesser le feu
et ça n'a pas plu à Benyamin netaniaahou
le Premier ministre Isra on dire que
l'escalade lexicale de Macron lui a valu
les foudres d'Israël le président de
l'État Isaac Herzog suggère qu'à la
faveur d'un échange téléphonique son
homologue français aurait nuancé voir
corriger son propos version contestée
par l'Élysée et le Premier ministre
Benjamin netanahou qui lucru n'a que
faire de tels entrechats diplomatiques
et s'est d'ailleurs empressé de fustiger
une erreur factuelle et morale en détant
moins tragique la formule prê à sourire
menteur compulsif bibi entretient avec
la vérité des faits des rapports au
mieux distendus quant à la morale
comment oublier que s'il a pactisé avec
une extrême droite aussi raciste que des
votes s'il s'acharne à museler la
justice de son pays c'est pour échapper
aux poursuites qu'on déclencha ces
multiples turpitudes alors comment
expliquer cette apparente correction de
trajectoire de l'Élysée de la même de
son entourage Emmanuel Macron a pris la
mesure du ressentiment qu'inspire au
monde musulman l'alignement supposé de
l'Occident global sur Israël ou à tout
le moins sa mansuétude envers les
ravages de la campagne dangeresse de de
tsal même si la fameuse politique arabe
de la france cet héritage que les
nostalgique du panage gaulien persiste à
magnifier à perdu l'essentiel de son
lustre Paris se doit de faire en sorte
que sa voie réputée singulière demeure
ou redevienne audible du CER à Jakarta
et donc il doute qu'un autre facteur
intérieur celui-là éclaire le numéro
d'équilibriste auquel se livre le
premier démarcheurs la hanentise d'une
importation du conflit
israël-palestinien de l'éclosion dans
l'Hexagone de métastases assez malignes
pour empoisonner le débat et enfiévrer
les banlieux gardons à l'esprit que la
France abrite plus ou moins la première
communauté juive d'Europe et que l'on y
recense près de 6 millions de musulmans
soit 10 % de sa population l'exécutif a
donc le devoir de conjurer le spectre de
l'embrasement et ce quoi qu'il en coûte
merci beaucoup Vincent pas le temps de
vous demander si vous cautionnez cette
inflexion présidentielle mais si on a le
temps vous réagirez à la chronique de
Fanny guinochem mais c'est une volte
phase vous veniez nous parler de cette
grogne qui allait monter dans le pays
avec la suppression des tickets resto
comme mode de paiement dans les
supermarchés et finalement le
gouvernement a décidé d'y renoncer ah
oui c'est en 24 heures c'était plié en
deux mots tout est parti du fait que
l'on a appris on a réalisé plutôt que
bientôt à partir du 1er janvier de
l'année prochaine il ne est plus
possible d'acheter tous les produits
alimentaires que l'on souhaite sauf
l'alcool et et et les confiseries avec
les tickets restaurant aujourd'hui c'est
ce que vous pouvez faire et là avec la
le changement à partir de l'année
prochaine vous alliez être cantonné avec
vos ticket restaurant à prendre des
menus enfin des des plats préparés donc
des sandwiches et cetera le meilleur
exemple c'est les sushis vous pouvez
acheter des sushis mais donc préparé
mais par le riz et euh le le saumon ça
ça n'était plus possible ça c'était
parce qu'il y avait eu une une
dérogation temporaire pendant le covid
qui faisait que on étendait à tous les
aliments l'achat des tickets resto mais
voilà en 24 heur ça a commencé à à
monter à monter et vous l'aviez bien
senti et Olivia Grégoire a annoncé
quelques minutes avant cette émission
qu'on allait prolonger cette dérogation
alors pendant 1 an évidemment pourquoi
par parce que il y avait tous les
ingrédients pour une petite bombe
sociale version petite mèche qui prend
comme vous vous souvenez au moment des
des aPL les allocation personnalisé au
logement on augmente de 5 € puis on se
rend pas compte et puis ça fait un
incendie social et bien là c'est
exactement ce qu' a craint le
gouvernement parce qu'en fait ces
tickets restaurants les gens les
utilisent les ménages les utilisent
beaucoup pour faire leur cours et en
période d'inflation élevée c'était
compliqué de dire au ménage et bien
écoutez on va vous vous restreindre par
ailleurs ça voulait dire inciter les
Français à se tourner vers des produits
préparés al ou la mal bouffe alors que
voilà alors qu'on a des produits
industriels alors qu'on a un
gouvernement qui en même temps dit qu'il
faut plutôt faire du fait maison que
c'est meilleur pour un certain nombre de
de de raisons alors évidemment ceux qui
sont mécontents ce sont les
restaurateurs ils ont perdu la partie il
y a une prolongation d'un an reste à
voir quand même comment ça va se passer
pour en terme législatif réglementaire
pouvoir faire cette prolongation sans
sans difficultéation rassuré c'est la
sagesse qui a parlé du gouvernement
c'était très favorable au ticket resto
mais je je note que dans un an on verra
quelle sera la la prochaine décision en
tout ça fébrilité du gouvernement est
très impatient situation d'achat en
situation d'inflation je pense que c'est
un bon signal mais il faut rappel
surtout sur les produits on change nos
consommation [__] la mais c'est un
élargissement qui date de la situation
sanitaire oui du covid voilà du covid hm
hm bon ben voilà elle a réagi avant
votre chronique Fanny merci beaucoup et
merci pour la concision voilà merci
Vincent merci Elsa Merci à VOUS Florent
boud vous êtes bienvenu quand vous
voulez si vous il vous reste un peu de
temps avant cette bataille qui s'annonce
héque dans dans l'éissy ça commence le
11 novembre 11 décembre prochain et
d'ailleurs ce sera à suivre en
intégralité hein sur LCP très belle
soirée documentaire Jean-Pierre gracien
à
demain
[Musique]